salut c'est romain demi l'idée de
culture générale j'ai deux petites
choses importantes à vous dire avant que
la vidéo ne commence première chose ne
regardez pas la vidéo comme ça avec du
pop corn
[Musique]
si vous voulez retenir ce que vous allez
apprendre dans cette vidéo vous devez
prendre des notes les études sur la
mémorisation ne laisse aucune place au
doute ne pas prendre de notes égal
oubliez donc faites moi plaisir ouvrez
une application comme google docs viewer
note est noté ce qui est essentiel pour
vous au fur et à mesure seconde chose
que je dois vous dire la vidéo vous
allez regarder est extraite de ma
formation de culture générale qui
s'appelle culture express c'est une
formation qui permet d'acquérir
rapidement une bonne culture générale
sans se prendre la tête sans avoir à
lire ni à réfléchir elle couvre tous les
domaines de la culture générale elle
permet de maîtriser les connaissances
essentielles sur l'histoire de
l'humanité sur l'histoire de france en
économie en sciences politiques en
psychologie en sciences en littérature
en art en religion et enfin en
philosophie ah oui c'est important la
philo si ça vous intéresse je tesi un
coup d'oeil soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant haut à droite de
la vidéo soit en cliquant sur celui qui
est dans la description de cette vidéo
voila voila je vous ai dit ce que je
voulais vous dire maintenant je vous
laisse regarder la vidéo concentrez vous
préparez vous prendre des notes et puis
n'hésitez pas à m'écrire dans les
commentaires et moi je vous dis à la
prochaine
[Musique]
où
qu'est ce que l'art
l'art sauvera le monde a écrit
dostoïevski dans l'idiot je me souviens
d'une anecdote que m'avait raconté un
ami quand j'étais adolescent sa mère
avait trouvé des magazines
pornographiques et cachés dans les
affaires de son père et celui ci s'était
justifié en disant que c'était dollars
l'idée sous jacente à son argument c'est
que l'art est une activité dans la
noblesse intrinsèque a le pouvoir de
revaloriser des choses vulgaire ou
immoral les scandales de l'art
contemporain en apporte la preuve des
créations qui frappe l homme ordinaire
par leur simplicité pour ne pas dire
leur absence de sens ou par leur
obscénité accède au statut d'oeuvre et
entre dans les musées
l'argument du père de mon ami et révèle
également l'ambiguïté de la définition
de l'art si les frontières de l'art
était bien établie si nous savions dire
ce qui relève de son domaine et ce qui
n'en relève pas alors l'art ne serait
pas un prétexte facile dans cette leçon
je vais répondre aux questions suivantes
comment définir l'art comment classifier
les différents arts quel est le sens de
l'art y at il un progrès en art et enfin
qui sont les artistes
comment définir l'art pour moi qui suis
un amoureux de la clarté l'ambiguïté du
mot art est un vrai problème non
seulement sa définition fait débat mais
les acteurs du monde de l'art eux-mêmes
entretiennent le flou sur les réponses
possibles probablement pour tenir les
profanes à distance et parce que la
clarté menace le prestige de leur
profession
que signifie le mot art le nom comme un
art vient du latin ars qui signifie
habileté savoir-faire en adoptant la
perspective de l'étymologie l'arrêt donc
dans l'absolu une capacité à produire un
certain résultat il se pose
traditionnellement à la science conçu
comme une connaissance indépendante des
applications
l'art d'écrire dont je me sers en ce
moment même en rédigeant le script de
cette vidéo cette harpe par exemple être
définie comme l'ensemble des procédés
qui servent à produire le résultat que
je désire à savoir un texte qui
communiquent efficacement mes idées
c'est également dans ce sens que l'on
parle des arts martiaux c'est à dire
l'ensemble des procédés qui permettent
de gagner un combat c'est encore dans ce
sens général que l'on parle d'un homme
de l'art pour désigner un spécialiste
particulièrement compétent dans sa
spécialité
par exemple un chirurgien très habile
c'est dans ce sens que vauvenargues le
moraliste du xviiie siècle avait écrit
dans ses réflexions et maxime l'art de
plaire et l'art de tromper le sens
général du mot art a donné les
expressions suivantes les hardis
mécanique comme la menuiserie ou l'art
de l'ingénieur même si de nos jours nous
considérons l'ingénieur comme un
scientifique les beaux-arts qui ont pour
but comme leurs noms l'indiquent de
produire le beau vous avez certainement
entendu parler des écoles des beaux-arts
en france qui ont donné l'expression
faire les beaux-arts les principaux
beaux-arts sont la peinture la sculpture
la gravure l'architecturé et l'art
décoratif ou encore les arts libéraux
les sept disciplines étudiées dans les
facultés de philosophie au moyen âge
c'était dans le détail la grammaire la
rhétorique et la logique d'une part les
3 matières qui était appelé le tribute
et l'arithmétique la géométrie
l'astronomie et la musique d'autre part
les quatre matières appelé le quadrivium
mais la plupart du temps nous
n'employons plus le nom comme un art
dans le sens très générale d'une
capacité à produire un certain résultat
lorsque nous parlons de l'art avec un
grand a lorsque par exemple nous disons
c'est de l'art dans de tels cas l'art
désigne la production de la beauté par
l'homme tout particulièrement la beauté
visuelle ce qui réduit la robocar l'art
avec un grand a relève de ce qu'on
appelle l'esthétique je vais revenir sur
ce terme c'est dans ce sens que l'on
parle par exemple de l'art classique ou
de l'art baroque
j'appelle artiste celui qui crée des
formes a écrit andré malraux dans les
voix du silence un essai de psychologie
dollar bien sûr cette définition simple
est sujette à interprétation elle a
évolué elle a été remise en cause au
cours de l'histoire de l'art
qu'est ce que la beauté le nom commun
beauté vient du latin bellos be2 l us
qui signifie jolie gracieux élégant
l'étymologie ne nous est donc d'aucune
aide pour définir la beauté je vais donc
plutôt partir d'exemples la beauté et la
qualité de ce qui est beau et philosophe
disent d'ailleurs le beau mais comment
savoir si une chose est belle un paysage
par exemple est beau s'il déclenche en
moi la sensation qu'on qualifie
d'esthétique c'est à dire si le produit
sur mes sens une impression comparable à
celle que produisent toutes les choses
belles plus précisément un paysage est
beau s'il produit sur mon sens de la vue
qui est le sens le plus utilisé par
l'être humain une impression agréable
secrète avait déjà remarqué que la
beauté n'a de sens qu'à l'égard de la
vue et de l'ouïe mais c'est le sens de
la vue qui est l'élément crucial pour
définir la beauté au sens strict en
clair une chose est belle si la voir me
procure une impression agréable
la beauté se définit donc au sens strict
comme la qualité qui provoque l'émotion
esthétique chez l'homme c'est par
extension que l'on parle de la beauté de
choses qui ne sont pas aperçus par la
vue comme une chanson principalement
perceptible par le sens de l'ouïe ou un
poème perceptible par une combinaison
complexe de louis dans la mesure où le
poème doit être lu et de la vue dans la
mesure où le poème évoque des images
mais à quoi la beauté tient tel plus
fondamentalement à ma connaissance les
hommes n'ont pas donné de réponse simple
et claire à cette question mais deux
pistes me paraissent intéressantes
première piste sous le prisme de
l'histoire de l'humanité la beauté
serait la propriété visuelle des choses
qui sont favorables à la survie de
l'individu et de l'espèce par exemple un
beau paysage naturel est un milieu dans
lequel l espèce a pu prospérer ou encore
une belle femme et pour un homme une
femme fertile la beauté réside dans les
adaptations de l'observateur écrit
donald de simons dans vos boîtes de
humboldt seconde piste intéressante du
point de vue technique la beauté semble
surtout tenir à l'harmonie c'est à dire
au fait qu'une multiplicité d'éléments
divers forment une unité en concourant à
une même fin l'harmonie du corps humain
par exemple
comment la définition de l'art at elle
évolué l'évolution de la définition
s'explique par le rapport de l'art à
l'artisanat dans le premier cas de
figure ils sont confondus artisans
d'abord a écrit alain à propos de
l'artiste dans les arts et les dieux
dans les communautés où l'art est peu
développée au sens où les oeuvres d'art
produisent une émotion esthétique
limitée dans ces communautés l'artiste
est un artisan un homme habile dans un
art mécanique difficile un horloger par
exemple aux mains qui gagne sa vie en
produisant de beaux objets pour des
clients ainsi les grecs employés un seul
mot techno pour désigner l'habileté
manuelle et l'art l'habileté de
l'artisan le distingue certes de
l'ouvrier mais son statut social n'est
guère plus enviable il est comme lui un
travailleur manuel sans noblesse dans
l'histoire occidentale la confusion de
l'artiste et de l'artisan a eu cours
grosso modo jusqu'à la renaissance même
si certains créateurs de génie ont pu
s'en émanciper lors des périodes
d'épanouissement artistique et cela dès
l'antiquité
dans le deuxième cas de figure là
redépasse l'artisanat dès la fin du
14ème siècle en italie les peintres
revendique pour le progrès de leurs
compétences caractérisée par le pouvoir
de création par l'audace de
l'imagination et par l'extrême précision
du dessin il revendique pour cela un
statut social comparable à celui de la
poésie le génie léonard de vinci va
encore plus loin au 16e siècle il ajoute
à la peinture des dimensions qui relève
du raisonnement philosophique et de
l'exploration de la nature l'artiste se
met à signer ses oeuvres comme
l'écrivain signe ses livres mais c'est
seulement au xviie siècle que les
beaux-arts de vienne autonome par
rapport aux arts mécaniques
qui blâme à la peinture blâme à la
nature a écrit léonard de vinci dans ses
carnets
dans le troisième cas de figure enfin la
repère toute dimension artisanale le
mouvement qui accomplit cette évolution
est l'art contemporain qui n'est après
1945 héron fondamentalement avec la
tradition de l'art occidental en effet
la création de l'artiste ne repose
désormais plus sur un savoir faire et
une habileté de la main il n'a même plus
besoin d'être guillemets de mettre la
main à la pâte d'intervenir
personnellement dans la production de
l'objet d'art car la valeur artistique
de ses oeuvres réside dans l'originalité
de son concept et dans l'habileté de
l'artiste à le promouvoir il n'est plus
artisans mais théoriciens et
communicants j'illustrerai les trois cas
de figure avec des exemples concrets
dans les leçons du module
comment classifier les différents arts
l'ambiguïté de la définition de l'art
entraîne logiquement un problème de
nomenclature les classifications de
l'art varie selon les époques et les
systèmes de pensée je vais d'abord
évoqué les classifications les plus
courantes dollar général puis je vous
présenterai les hardis visuel qui sont
les plus essentiels pour votre culture
artistique
combien yat-il d'art différents à
prendre le mot art dans son sens général
différentes réponses sont possibles
l'antiquité grecque comptait neuf art
parce que sa mythologie compté autant de
mu les divinités fille de zeus qui
inspira les artistes ces neuf arçons la
poésie épique l'histoire la poésie
lyrique la musique la tragédie
l'éloquence la danse la comédie et
l'astronomie mais cette classification
n'est plus du tout la nôtre elle
comprend même et des disciplines qui
sont pour nous des sciences comme
l'astronomie ou l'histoire ensuite au
moyen âge avait cours à la
classification que j'ai déjà mentionné
des arts a dit libéraux par opposition
aux arts dits mécanique ce sont pour
rappel la grammaire la rhétorique et la
logique qui constitue le tri view et de
l'autre côté l'arithmétique la géométrie
l'astronomie et la musique qui constitue
le quadrivium en outre de grands
penseurs ont proposé des classifications
intéressante le philosophe allemand du
xviiie siècle quand distingué par
exemple les harkis forme des images la
peinture à la sculpture et
l'architecturé les arts de la parole et
les arts qui stimule les sensations tout
particulièrement la musique eagle un
autre philosophe allemand qui écrit une
génération après kant hegel voit pour sa
part 5 ares principaux dont ils estiment
que le pouvoir d'expression est fonction
de l'abstraction autrement dit plus un
art est abstrait plus il est expressif
se sont larchitecture le plus concret
donc le moins expressif la sculpture la
peinture la musique et la poésie le plus
abstrait donc le plus expressif enfin la
classification la plus courante de nos
jours et celle en vertu de laquelle nous
parlons du cinéma comme du septième art
les cet art sont l'architecturé la
sculpture la peinture et le dessin la
musique la littérature dont la poésie
les arts de la scène dont notamment le
théâtre et la danse et enfin le septième
art le cinéma et comme je voulais dit le
mot arabe désigne au sens strict les
trois premiers de cette classification
qu'on appelle également les arts visuels
quels sont les arts visuels majeur le
module de culture artistique de culture
express se concentre sur les trois haras
majeur de la tradition occidentale la
peinture la sculpture et l'architecturé
la peinture consiste à appliquer des
couleurs sur une surface les supports
privilégiés par les artistes sont la
toile le papier et le bois la couleur
est produite avec divers types de
substances l'aquarelle par exemple est
une peinture à l'eau sur papier il y a
également la peinture à l'huile la
joconde de léonard de vinci en est une
les peintres peuvent encore utilisé de
la cire de la grèce ou même d eux comme
dans la très ancienne technique de la
tempora tempel-1 qui existait déjà dans
l'egypte antique la sculpture consiste à
produire une belle forme en trois
dimensions les deux principales
catégories de sculptures sont le relief
défini par le fait que la forme me
repose sur un arrière-plan comme avec un
clavier d'ordinateur et puis la ronde
bosse qui peut être observée de tous les
côtés comme une statue par exemple les
matériaux privilégiés par les artistes
sont la pierre l'origine étymologique du
mot sculpture le latin school perret et
c'est ul per eux signifie d'ailleurs
tailler la pierre donc la pierre le bois
le métal ou encore des matières
végétales les techniques de création de
la forme varie selon le matériau le
modelage de la terre notamment et la
technique la plus ancienne la taille
consiste à retrancher un certain volume
d'une matière dure comme la pierre et
enfin l'assemblage consiste comme son
nom l'indiqué à joindre des éléments
comme lorsque l'on soude des pièces de
métal
l' architecture consiste à construire à
disposer et à orner les édifices
étymologiquement le terme vient du mot
grec a requis ar karachi qui commande et
textone t&e kto n ouvriers l'
architecture serait donc l'art de
commander aux ouvriers est effectivement
en pratique sur un chantier moderne
l'architecte leur donne des directives
dans le détail cet art comporte
plusieurs dimensions l'architecte vise
non seulement à créer un bâtiment qui
plaisent à l'oeil mais il doit aussi
prévoir la solidité de l'édifice lusage
que les hommes en feront ou encore son
intégration dans l'environnement il a
par là dans l'organisation de la vie
collective un rôle en vertu duquel on le
compare à une intelligence ordonnatrice
comme le grand architecte de l'univers
dans la théologie franc maçonne ou
l'architecte dans le film matrix
ce qui distingue d'emblée le père
architecte de la bei est la plus experte
c'est qu'il a construit la cellule dans
sa tête avant de la construire dans la
ruche écrit karl marx dans le capital
quels sont les autres arts visuels
importants ont également compté dans
l'histoire de l'art mais dans une
moindre mesure à côté de la peinture de
la sculpture et de l' architecture le
dessin qui consiste à représenter
quelque chose sur une surface au moyen
d'un crayon d'une plume ou d'un pinceau
c'est souvent une étape préparatoire qui
permet à l'artiste de concrétiser
rapidement son idée est de la présenter
aux commanditaires la gravure qui
consiste à creuser une matière comme la
pierre le bois ou en métal grâce à
divers outils pour créer une
représentation
l'orfèvrerie qui consiste à fabriquer de
beaux objets en métaux précieux surtout
l'or qui a donné son nom à l'art mais
aussi l'argent par exemple la mosaïque
pratiqué dans la rome antique notamment
qui consiste à utiliser des fragments ap
les tesselles t e 2 se2 élu-es des
fragments de pierre des mailles de verre
ou encore de céramique pour créer des
représentations et enfin a également
compté dans l'histoire de l'art l'art du
vitrail qui s'est développée au moyen
âge et qui consiste à assembler des
pièces de verre de couleur pour créer
une représentation c'est une manière
artistique de laisser passer la lumière
dans un bâtiment
quel est le sens de l'art je vais
d'abord évoqué les idées des grands
penseurs de l'antiquité je vous
présenterai ensuite les thèses de
référence sur le sens de l'art enfin je
verrai comment expliquer l'effet de la
révolution scientifique et industrielle
sur le sens de l'art
comment les penseurs quitter voit-il
l'art les deux plus grands philosophes
de l'antiquité grecque platon et son
disciple aristote on t'oublie de
réfléchir au sens de l'art la réflexion
de platon est intéressante à deux égards
tout d'abord la définition de l'art
commis mais si ce qui signifie
imitations en grec ancien platon
condamne ce que nous appelons les
beaux-arts qui n'existe pas en tant que
tel dans son propos parce que les
beaux-arts ne reproduisent les choses
que dans leur apparence par exemple une
peinture ne rend qu'un seul aspect d'un
lit contrairement à l'objet matériel qui
possède l'unité d'une chose et ce qui a
le plus de valeur pour platon c'est
l'idée du lit c'est à dire le modèle
intellectuel et qui guident l'artisan
dans son travail un tableau n'est donc
dans cette perspective qu'un simulacre
de l'objet fabriqué par l'homme platon
mais le peintre au même rang que le
poète et que le sophiste le peintre est
un illusionniste seconde choses
intéressantes dans la réflexion de
platon l'essence du bo la définition du
bo de platon tient en trois étages en
premier lieu une chose est belle en
elle-même lorsqu'elle procure un plaisir
sans mélange c'est à dire un plaisir pur
qui ne naît pas de la cessation d'une
peine ensuite une chose est belle si
elle est harmonieuse idée que j'ai déjà
évoqué enfin elle est belle si elle
conduit le spectateur vers l'essence
supra sensible de la beauté c'est à dire
si elle l aide à comprendre ce qui est
fondamentalement la beauté
la réflexion d'aristote est elle aussi
intéressante à deux égards tout d'abord
aristote dévalorise les arts manuels
entre guillemets aristote distingue
d'une part les arts mécaniques dont la
peinture l'architecturé la sculpture qui
produisent des objets et d'autre part à
les arts libéraux comme la rhétorique
les mathématiques et la musique qui
produisent des objets intellectuelle les
arts libéraux sont nobles tandis que les
arts mécaniques qui mobilise le corps
sont serviles cette classification des
arts expliqué l'infériorité social de
l'artiste
seconde chose intéressante dans la
réflexion d'aristote limitation de la
nature aristote ne dis pas que la
reproduit des copies de la nature
aristote dit que l'art imite la nature
en tant que force créatrice il agence eu
lui aussi des moyens en vue d'une fin la
nature comme est certes moins d'erreurs
que l'art qui est victime de la
délibération et de l'ama l'habilité
humaine mais la nature est impuissante à
créer certains objets sans la main de
l'homme qui puisse la compléter
l'art ou bien exécute ce que la nature
est impuissante à effectuer ou bien ils
limitent écrit aristote dans sa physique
quels sont les thèses de référence sur
le sens de l'art la réflexion
philosophique sur le sens de la recette
approfondie depuis quand en voici les
thèses les plus pénétrantes dans sa
critique de la faculté de juger dont la
première partie est la critique de la
faculté de juger esthétique quand
caractérise la beauté d'une oeuvre d'art
par le fait que l'appréciation doit être
partagé par tous ainsi lorsqu'on trouve
une chose belle on présuppose que cette
beauté est une propriété de la chose qui
doit être reconnue universellement nous
attribuons aux autres la même
satisfaction en revanche lorsqu'on
trouve une chose agréable le goût du vin
par exemple on juge selon son goût
personnel sans présupposés qu'il en est
de même pour autrui est beau ce qui
plaît universellement sans concept écrit
quand dans sa critique de la faculté de
juger
eagle affirme de sony que l'art est une
des voies par lesquelles la conscience
humaine se manifestent les étapes de
l'histoire de l'art en apporte la preuve
l'art symbolique ou orientale à
manifeste une volonté d'infini l'art
classique manifeste un équilibre parfait
entre la forme et le contenu et enfin
l'art romantique manifeste l'importance
de l'intériorité de l'individu eagle
estime que l'art meurt à son époque
parce qu'il n'est plus le meilleur moyen
d'exprimer la conscience humaine
dans le monde comme volonté et comme
représentation de schopenhauer définit
l'art comme un mode d'accès à la vérité
de l'existence mode d'accès qui est
affranchi de la logique du désir et du
logiciel de l'esprit humain
cette conception aura une grande
influence sur les artistes européens à
partir de la seconde moitié du 19e
siècle
dans la théorie marxiste l'art est un
des moyens par lesquels une classe
sociale exprime la conscience qu'elle a
d'elle-même sur le plan des rapports de
force entre les classes sociales l'art
constitue une des dimensions du
phénomène d'hégémonie culturelle
identifiés par antonio gramsci ainsi
l'art des société bourgeoise est une et
des armes idéologiques qui empêche la
classe des prolétaires de prendre
conscience de ses propres enjeux
politiques
nietzsche remet en question le mythe du
génie de l'artiste notamment dans humain
trop humain aucune oeuvre humaine quelle
qu'elle soit n'est le produit d'un
miracle elle est toujours le fruit d'un
important effort méthodique aux yeux de
nietzsche les artistes entretiennent
l'illusion afin de se démarquer des
artisans et les spectateurs y croit pour
justifier leurs émotions esthétiques
dans la distinction bourdieu réfléchir
au sens de l'art dans le cadre des
rapports de classe comme la classe
sociale dominante est celle qui
détermine la hiérarchie des productions
culturelles la culture et le goût
artistique sont des attributs
symboliques qui marque l'appartenance à
la classe sociale dominante
le progrès technique rend-il l'art
inutile on peut comprendre le problème à
partir d'exemples simples à quoi bon
commandé un tableau quand je peux
prendre une photo à quoi bon passer du
temps devant une statue quand je peux
avoir l'image dans mon iphone
la révolution scientifique et
industrielle des sociétés occidentales
bouleversé le monde de l'art en effet le
mode de production artisanale celui de
l'artiste disparaît au profit du mode de
production industrielle qui consiste à
produire une grande quantité du même
produit en associant les machines et des
travailleurs de la manière la plus
efficiente possible
l'historien de l'art allemand du 20e
siècle walter benjamin affirme dans
l'oeuvre d'art à l'époque de sa
reproductibilité technique que la
technique moderne change le statut de
l'oeuvre d'art certes les élèves
recopier leurs maîtres dans les ateliers
mais la reproduction de masse par
l'imprimerie la gravure la photographie
puis les processus photo mécaniques
chimiques et électriques cela change
complètement la donne
lusage de la sérigraphie l'imprimerie
par pochoir dans le pop art le mouvement
incarné par andy warhol dans les années
1960 lusage de la sérigraphie est un
exemple emblématique de cette évolution
les nft les oeuvres d'art numérique
radicalise la mutation au milieu des
années 2010
voici précisément comment walter
benjamin explique l'effet du progrès
technique sur l'art dans les sociétés
prix industriels l'oeuvre d'art avait
une aura puisqu'elle était unique la
contempler était une expérience unique
source d'une émotion esthétique unique
comme l'est la contemplation d'un beau
paysage naturel dans les sociétés
industrielles l'oeuvre et l'expérience
de contemplation n'ont plus rien
d'unique c'est pourquoi l'art a perdu la
valeur d'usagé qu'il avait pour l'être
humain walter benjamin n'en concluent
cependant pas que le progrès technique
rend l'art inutile seulement ils
transforment profondément les conditions
de production et de consommation de
l'oeuvre d'art
à l'époque de la reproductibilité
technique écrit walter benjamin
ce qui dépérit dans l'oeuvre d'art
c'est son aura je vous expliquerai dans
la leçon sur l'art moderne l'incidence
du progrès technique sur les idées qui
anima les artistes et sur le monde de
l'art en général
y at il un progrès en art mon père est
tombé sur ce sujet à son oral de philo
du bac il ya plus de 40 ans mais la
question d'un progrès c'est à dire d'une
transformation graduelle du moins bien
au mieux en matière d'art cette question
est bien plus ancien pour l'étudier je
vais vous présenter dans un ordre
d'évidence décroissante c'est à dire du
plus évident moins évident trois
arguments en faveur de la thèse puis
trois arguments qui s'y opposent
quels sont les arguments en faveur de
cette thèse en premier lieu on peut
avancer que les produits sont meilleures
autrement dit les oeuvres s'améliorerait
avec le temps c'est à dire que l'émotion
esthétique qu'elle suscite chez le
spectateur est plus puissante l'émotion
est plus intense et plus profondes
l'émotion est plus complexe les
peintures des génie de la renaissance
italienne apparaissent par exemple plus
réussie que celle des meilleurs peintres
du moyen âge cela peut s'expliquer par
la supériorité de leurs qualités
techniques le dessin est peut-être plus
précis les proportions mieux respecter
les couleurs mieux accorder etc
cependant cet argument n'est pas valable
pour toutes les époques historiques
l'art peut même régresser comme cela fut
le cas après l'apogée de l'antiquité
gréco-romaine
en deuxième lieu on peut avancer que les
artistes sont plus compétents
si les produits de l'art paraissent plus
réussi à une époque qu précédente c'est
en partie parce que les artistes
possèdent une meilleure maîtrise que
leurs aînés ou bien qu'ils aient
maîtrise de nouvelles techniques
inconnus de leurs aînés par exemple
l'emploi de la perspective par les
peintres italiens du 15e siècle s'est
traduit par un progrès en terme de
réalisme l'image paraît bien plus fidèle
à la réalité plus fondamentalement le
progrès de la compétence des artistes
est rendue possible par leur inscription
dans une tradition une génération
transmet ses compétences à la suivante
laquelle s'efforcera à son tour d'élever
le niveau d'habileté cet argument est
toutefois à relativiser par le fait
qu'un artiste n'est pas forcé de
s'inscrire dans la tradition de ses
aînés
l'art ne progresse pas comme la science
enfin on peut avancer que les médiums
sont plus efficaces la capacité des
supports des arts visuels à produire
l'émotion esthétique s'améliore avec le
temps par exemple le mur d'une église
qui accueille une fresque est un
meilleur médium que le mur d'une grotte
où un homme préhistorique 1 du gibier et
une toile préparée pour accueillir à la
peinture et à divers égards un meilleur
médium qu'un mur on peut même comparé
l'efficacité des médiums entre
différents arts une vidéo ne produit tel
pas une émotion esthétique supérieure à
celle produite par une peinture on peut
néant objecté à cet argument que c'est
la technologie au sens large qui
progresse et non pas l'habileté à
produire de la beauté elle même
quels sont les arguments qui s'opposent
à cette thèse en premier lieu on peut
avancer que l'art ne s'épanouit pas à
toutes les époques ainsi certaines
périodes apparaissent comme des apogée
artistique tandis que d'autres nous
laisse peu de chefs-d'oeuvre par exemple
la haute renaissance italienne qu'on
appelle le think we cento cette période
a accouché de trois des plus grands
génies de l'art occidental léonard de
vinci de michel-ange et raphaël les
réussites de ces artistes étaient si
éblouissante que la génération suivante
en a été désarçonné comment soutenir la
comparaison avec les chefs-d'oeuvre de
leurs aînés
en deuxième lieu on peut avancer que les
oeuvres d'art ne sont pas comparables ce
qui rend impossible la conclusion d'un
progrès en effet s'il existe bien une
tradition artistique qui favorise la
continuité par imitation les générations
d'artistes cherche également à se
différencier les unes des autres le
courant des peintres impressionnistes au
19e siècle a par exemple rompu avec la
tradition en renonçant à l' usage
académique de la lumière et en
s'écartant des sujets admis l'historien
de l'art ernst gombrich estime ainsi que
l'histoire de l'art et sous sa forme la
plus simple l'histoire de la succession
des styles
chaque génération et dans une certaine
mesure en révolte contre les critères de
la génération précédente écrit-il dans
son histoire de l'art
enfin on peut avancer que l'état de la
civilisation conditionne le
développement de l'art il n'y aurait
donc pas de progrès dans la mesure où
avant d'essayer de se surpasser les uns
les autres les artistes de travail avec
les contraintes de leur contexte socio
économique la prospérité décuple les
commandes et peut même créer un rapport
de force favorable aux créateurs qui
pourra suivre sa propre inspiration
plutôt que de se contenter d'exécuter le
projet du commanditaire en revanche une
morale sociale austère empêche les
artistes d'exprimer librement leurs
talents et les cantonne aux arts les
plus rémunérateurs par exemple comme le
protestantisme est hostile aux images
dont il craint qu'elle éloigne le fidèle
du message originel du christianisme son
avènement au 16e siècle a brutalement
réduit l'activité des peintres du nord
de l'europe le portrait est le seul
genre qui survit
qui sont les artistes je veux d'abord
vous parler de la formation des artistes
je vous résume devrait ensuite les
caractéristiques essentielles de la
condition de l'artiste enfin
j'analyserai cette condition sous un
angle spécifiquement économique en
m'intéressant au marché de l'art
comment devient ton artiste
professionnel l'habileté de l'artiste
est le fruit d'un apprentissage
historiquement la formation des peintres
et des sculpteurs était calquée sur
celle du monde de l'artisanat les
artistes les plus réputés dirige des
ateliers où les artistes en devenir se
forment par la pratique au début
l'apprenti se contente d'observer puis
il s'implique de plus en plus dans les
projets jusqu'à devenir lui même est
capable de diriger un projet de a à z
auquel cas il a le niveau pour créer son
propre atelier par exemple léonard de
vinci s'est formé dans l'atelier le plus
important de florence celui du très
renommé peintre et sculpteur andrea del
verrocchio v er au 2 chio puis léonard
de vinci a ouvert son propre atelier à
25 ans les choses ont changé au tournant
du 19e siècle les peintres et les
sculpteurs sont désormais formés dans un
système edy académique c'est à dire
inspiré de l'école où platon enseigné au
début du 4e siècle avant jésus-christ
l'enseignement est plus intellectuel les
élèves étudient les chefs-d'oeuvre
anciens pour en assimiler la maîtrise
technique à ma connaissance les
véritable autodidacte sont plutôt rares
dans l'histoire de l'art même s'il ya
des exemples étonnants comme van gogh
mais la formation de l'artiste comporte
bien sûr plus ou moins une par
d'autodidacte si les peintres polymathe
de la renaissance en sont le meilleur
exemple qui ont énormément appris en
dehors de l'atelier il existe
aujourd'hui en france une quarantaine
d'écoles supérieures d'art public la
plus connue étant les beaux-arts de
paris et à cela il faut ajouter les
écoles privées plutôt que des peintres
ou des sculpteurs les établissements
forment des graphistes des créateurs
numérique des photographes des vidéastes
des médiateurs des animateurs etc
la formation des architectes a connu la
même évolution
le maître d'oeuvre l'ancêtre de
l'architecte transmettait directement
ses compétences à ses assistants puis
son nez des institutions académiques qui
délivre un enseignement théorique et des
diplômes dans certains pays comme la
france l' architecture est une
profession réglementée
le titre d'architecte est conditionnée à
l'obtention du diplôme délivré par la
vingtaine d'écoles d'architecturé
et contrôlée par l'ordre des architectes
quelle est la condition de l'artiste sa
condition et pendant le plus clair de
l'histoire de l'art celle de l'artisan
en voici les trois caractéristiques
principales tout d'abord la précarité
les revenus de la plupart des artistes
professionnels sont faibles et un
certain puisqu'ils sont des
entrepreneurs il n'est pas rare qu'ils
doivent accepter un travail alimentaire
pour assurer le vivre et le couvert
toutefois il se protège en s'organisant
en corporations comme les artisans en
outre il existe bien une minorité plus
ou moins large selon les périodes
d'artistes qui s'enrichissent grâce à
leur talent c'est un préjugé de croire
qu'un artiste ne peut pas connaître le
succès de son vivant et que ces oeuvres
ne seront reconnus à leur vraie valeur
qu'après sa mort les deux scénarios
existent dans l'histoire de l'art
deuxième caractéristique de la condition
de l'artiste la servitude créative
l'artiste travaille le plus souvent à la
commande c'est à dire qu'il met son
habilité au service de la réalisation
d'un projet désiré et imaginé par
d'autres il existe certes une marge dans
laquelle il peut exprimer sa créativité
mais elle est souvent mince car les
clients s'attendent en général à ce qui
limite un modèle traditionnel
enfin troisième et dernière
caractéristique de la condition de
l'artiste l'infériorité sociale
l'artiste étant un artisan c'est à dire
un travailleur manuel son statut social
est inférieur à celui de l'écrivain
pendant bien longtemps il ne signe pas
son travail et c'est l'oeuvre elle seule
qui reçoit l'estiment public certains
artistes stars entre guillemets réussi à
s'extirper de cette condition difficile
dans les période d'épanouissement
culturel comme le sculpteur lysippe elle
y est hideuse pe qui était le
portraitiste officiel d'alexandre le
grand mais c'est surtout à partir de la
renaissance que la condition de
l'artiste s'améliore le rapport de force
économique évolue en la faveur de
l'artiste car les élites multiplié les
commandes ambitieuse et les grands
maîtres donne à l'art visuel une
dimension intellectuelle qui rapproche
leur statut social de celui de
l'écrivain
à partir de la révolution française le
monde des artistes se divisent
progressivement
parler très schématiquement en deux
groupes d'un côté les académiques entre
guillemets profitent de
l'institutionnalisation de l'art pour
s'assurer une situation confortable de
l'autre côté les marginaux entre
guillemets rompre avec l'académisme
sacrifient leur confort quotidien et
renoncent à la reconnaissance immédiate
afin d'exprimer leur créativité
c'est dans ce groupe que ce range la
figure de l'artiste maudit incarné par
van gogh qu'en est il de la condition
des métiers artistiques aujourd'hui en
france les sociologues disent que les
métiers auxquels forme les écoles d'art
mais en général à des emplois précaires
dépendants et éloigné de la vocation
initiale mais après tout la désillusion
n'est-elle pas un passage obligé de
l'entrée sur le marché du travail pour
brosser un tableau statistique grossier
la france compterait à la fin des années
2010 environ 60000 artistes
professionnels et plus de la moitié
dépendrait des aides sociales étant
donné cette précarité les meilleurs
débouchés d'une formation artistique
sont bien souvent un poste dans
l'enseignement ou dans l'administration
publique
qu'est ce que le marché de l'art on peut
se [ __ ] de la gueule de l'art mais pas
de la gueule du marché a dit damien
hirst la star de l'art contemporain des
années 1990
l'emballement financiers autour de l'art
contemporain a popularisé l'expression
de marché de l'art mais l'art n'a jamais
échapper à la logique économique
son prestige tend à nous faire oublier
les considérations matérielles mais les
artistes ont en réalité comme les
écrivains l'obsession de vivre de leur
talent
voici les acteurs lionel du marché de
l'art l'artiste le producteur qui
travaille seul ou au sein d'une petite
entreprise l'atelier le commanditaire
l'acheteur qui est en général une
institution religieuse ou politique un
membre de l'élite politique ou
économique ou bien un bourgeois qui veut
faire faire son portrait par exemple les
corporations ou guilde dans lesquels les
artistes s'associent à l'image des
artisans pour défendre leurs intérêts
communs certaines corporations
deviennent puissante à la renaissance et
enfin les marchands d'art apparu à la
renaissance qui servent d'intermédiaires
entre l'artiste et l'acheteur avec le
temps certains marchands se
spécialiseront dans les oeuvres
nouvelles d'autres dans les anciennes et
des multinationales comme christie's et
sotheby's ont été créées par des
marchands d'art britannique en
l'occurrence comme je voulais déjà dit
d'ordinaire le rapport de forces est
favorable aux commanditaires l'artiste a
également du mal à se passer du marchand
qui contrôle l'accès aux acheteurs le
commanditaire et le marchand impose donc
leurs conditions le prix le style et
c'est aux artistes mais ceux ci
s'organise pour ramener l'équilibré en
leur faveur la plupart du temps les
commanditaires achète les oeuvres je
parle surtout des biens meubles les
peintures et des sculptures la plupart
du temps ils achètent les oeuvres pour
en jouir mais le motif de spéculation et
de plus en plus courant à mesure que se
développe le marché de l'art et que se
multiplient par voie de conséquence les
opportunités de faire un profit de
nouveaux acteurs s'impose et à partir du
19ème siècle l'état qui intervient plus
ou moins selon les pays à la fois en
régissant le goût par exemple en créant
des académies en commandant des oeuvres
pour les musées notamment voir en
prétendant administrer le monde de l'art
un peu comme en france et puis second
nouveaux acteurs qui s'impose à partir
du 19ème siècle les critiques qui
guident le public dans l'appréciation
des oeuvres leur fonction est justifiée
par le développement et par la
complexification du marché de l'art
enfin l'avènement de l'art contemporain
après la seconde guerre mondiale à
révolutionne le marché de l'art
autrefois renier la logique économique
vient alors une dimension essentielle et
assumée de l'activité artistique je vous
expliquerai en détail cette révolution
dans la leçon consacrée à l'art
contemporain
alors la vidéo vous a plu j'espère que
oui je vous rappelle que c'est un
extrait de ma formation culture générale
culture express si vous voulez en savoir
plus cliquez sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant aux audois de les vidéos ou
bien sur celui qui est dans la
description de cette vidéo voila voila
comme d'habitude n'hésitez pas à
m'écrire dans les commentaires et puis
surtout n'oubliez pas que vous n'avez
pas besoin de vous prendre la tête pour
vous cultiver